I dunno, like for me, I love the feeling, especially in summer when it's hot,
just taking like a nice, a nice cold shower. It's a little different though.
That's a, that's a bit different, but like eat, like even now,
now in the winter I take like three showers. Like I get a bit cold showers,
three showers sometimes. Why not? Not,
not like the one you don't upload videos in the shower. Not, not, not like,
not like properly long showers. Just like sometimes I get a bit cold. Like,
yeah. Like, like I said, my mind, like either I'm too stuffy or I'm too cold.
So sometimes I can't be bothered to wait for the heater to go on just popping
the shower, like get a bit of warm water on me. All right.
I'm back up to walk. This man spends more time in the shower, thinking of ideas.
The next one could be this.
It's not the clown. Here's the whole circus. You know, it's also up as well.
About you gone hate to bully you this episode,
but you don't use your bath at all. Do you took that?
I sit down. I look nice. I mean, okay.
I don't like taking a bath in, like,
it feels like I'm in like a prison cell bath. You know what I mean?
I feel like I'm taking like, okay, so Japanese boss are tiny.
They're not bad yours. Isn't that bad. You can, you can see. Okay.
If I can't stretch my legs out in the bath, then it's not even a bath to me.
It's a glorified sink in that. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
The point is you have to take a bath, like, like this, you do the
[inaudible] position. Like, okay.
I take, like, I would say 90% baths, 10% showers,
honestly, honestly, because in Japan, right?
The best thing is is that you can like reserve your bath. Yeah. Yeah.
As it says, which is like, if you know what time you're waking up,
you can set the bath to be full and hot by that time.
Which why the do we not have this biggest brain?
Like w they have like NASA in the U S but they haven't figured out how to
schedule a bath. Like, I know what time I'm going to wake up.
I know what someone needs to be in that bathtub.
Why can I not do this basic function? Right.
And then also you have one button you don't like, because in the UK, right.
What you have to do is just turn the tap on and keep checking on it.
Every five minutes, pain, the in Japan,
there's one button that fills it up to the perfect amount of the amount that you
set at the exact temperature that you set. How is this is the future, man.
Like, why wouldn't I take a bath?
I just feel like for me, baths are just not,
I'm not ergo ergonomically designed for me. Cause like,
I feel like I'm too tall to properly appreciate a good bath.
That much taller than call it that much taller than me.
Because like I love on sense. Right?
The reasons I love on-center is I'm submerged in water and I'm in a comfortable
position.
I can never get in a comfortable position in any of any of the baths I've ever
owned in my life because here's, here's the issue, right?
So I want to stress my legs out, but then my body is above the water.
So you go submerge yourself and then you submerge and then your body just gets
caught, right?
Peak, peak bath position. Right? It's like the water's up to like,
here are your arms out of the tub. You'll be watching something there,
but that's the best.
As well. Cause then your upper body is like cold. I like.
Perfect temperature control because your head is, is like free.
You've got this bit getting cold. And then you got the restaurant.
Also because the bath water is so hot. It, the,
the hop like the steam from the hot water makes the room warm as well.
Yeah.
It's I feel like you just haven't given baths the true shot they deserve gone.
I pan again, you're wasting another potential of Japan,
which is how good the bath saw.
Way too small. I don't want to be city. If my, if my legs are cold,
then that's not a bath to me. I w what we're doing, you're not daddy,
long legs in this. Like, I'm going to your house.
Bots are meant to be relaxing. And I need,
I need to be in a comfortable position to be in a relaxed.
That's why I love onsens and I just don't take boss showers, showers to me.
I just more or less.
I don't believe next time I'll go in your house.
I'm forcing you to get in the bath with your clothes on.
I want to judge this position. That's. I don't believe you.
Yeah. We have one in the studio go in this one that one's tiny as well.
That one's too.
Yeah. But we'll get gone in there. What's going on? Yeah.
The other thing of like,
I like the only times I've had barfs is in my home in England and I don't know,
like the way okay. Like Jew. Okay. When you're in a bath,
do you put your legs towards the top or did you put like your back towards the
top legs, legs towards the towel animals fed back towards the top?
Because the top is always like, I don't know. I always have, like,
I don't know if it's just me, but sometimes,
sometimes I like accidentally hit the tap and it's either too hot or too cold.
And it just like ruins the entire vibe for me. You want the legs.
There? Cause like you want to burn your back.
Yeah. I've actually done that before. And I think that's just,
I don't think it matches [inaudible].
So you're back at your parents' house. It wasn't that nice. Come on. Gone.
Come on. You can do better than that.
I mean, like, even if I'm in a nice hotel, I'm like, I don't take it away.
There's nothing better than an hotel. That is a big aspect. I agree.
That's like the only time where I'm exclusively, like showers.
I'm going in that bar. Always, always, always.
I like the feeling of just having like water, like spraying on you. I dunno.
It's just like a nice go out into the rain. Honestly.
I honestly like rain in Southeast Asia is
great. Okay. Cause I like, we, we, when we think of rain,
we think of like cold depressing, British rain,
just it's like, God blew up raspberry and you, and I hate that for you.
Right. But in, in Thailand when it rains, it pause. Right.
And it's probably like, and it's warm as well. It's like taking a warm shower.
It doesn't feel like you're just getting on.
So humid.
Cause it was doing that in Japan and the summit was raining and it was like
deceiving because I'm like, finally I'll be cold. Yeah. But no,
it was just more heat directly applied to my skin. That's what I hated when,
when I went to.
Uh, the Philippines, like for the first time and it was like, may,
so it wasn't even like properly hot yet. But because it's,
this is Southeast Asia, it's still hot in may.
And the moment I got outside my hair just turned into an Afro because of the
amount of humidity. And then there was a pool where we were staying.
So I was like, Oh, thank God.
I can finally jump in the pool and I'll call myself off. No,
because it was so humid outside. It was like walking into a puddle of.
Like it was, it was, it was horrible. I was, I like,
I like heated pools and not like regular poles,
but the temperature of this poll is like halfway in between of that.
And it was just like, lukewarm.
What else makes you feel like someone is in it? It doesn't,
it doesn't make the water feel clean. It's like perfect bacteria, temperature,
please feel real gross. Exactly.
That's why cold showers are like amazing. They are amazing.
That's why like when I used to swim in public pools,
the best ones are like the ones that are initially cold.
But you get warm as you sweating. Cause that's like nice.
Cause it also forces you to keep swimming and you don't get too comfortable.
The ones where you're just like, you feel the water and you're like, Oh,
that's called,
but I'm just going to commit and just fully jump in and submerge my body all at
once. And then you'll find after that. Yeah.
I'm like this. I can't believe you're an animal con.
You can take them out of Thailand where you can't take the peasant. Sorry.
Sorry. The Thailand though. I messed that up.
I have the superior taste. I'm just don't eat cross.
I just want to exist happily. You know what I mean? That's that's.
I want you to exist correctly. God, I want you to use the day when you can.
And I want you to take a bath every night, treat yourself, treat yourself.
Don't want better than that. I don't want a wet.
You don't have to be wipe. That's what toilet paper was invented.
I don't want wet fingers after a while. That's just.
Pouring your out with your hands. What are you doing? Bailey in your hands.
Don't get wet. We use a day. Do they see? That is disgusting.
That's why I hate it.
Yeah, I am using, he's just using his hands.
He's using the heat of friction to warm his back up to
evaporate the water, his cheeks. What are you doing? God, you know what?
I want to watch your after this. I want to see what you're doing.
I need to judge your technique. You're doing it all wrong. do it. I'm ready.
reveal. Let's go.
We're going to go pro inside of the toilet bowl and see what's going now.
Why one of the day came just to see, I need to see what's going on.
You do it in this bowl guard.
Next special day,
special official will God be able to learn how to use a bid day correctly?